what are a few of the things you do to
try to get people out of their own way
in terms of teaching and writing in that
regard one thing that I love doing when
I'm doing workshops is having like a
free write and I will pick something a
topic something that's happened to me
that week or or something that's that's
either like making me really happy or
really bothering me be in the world it
can be personal and all of that and I
will ask people to write just like let's
spend the first half hour of the class
just writing about that and and that
could be I was on the phone yesterday
and before I knew it I was saying things
that I really regret and I couldn't take
back have you have you been on the phone
and said things to someone who you
really care about that you really regret
and and you can't take back and of
course everyone has and people will
write and because again I I will be sort
of ruthlessly honest with myself it will
give people permission to be honest with
themselves and and and some of the most
amazing writing I've had come out of my
workshop are those free rights and and
and it's and it's writing there's going
to be so much rejection there's going to
be so much indifference there's going to
be there's going to be so so many people
saying no other people do that you don't
do that no other people make movies you
don't make movies
I was I was with a very talented writer
a director on
on Sunday night it was from Georgia and
was talking about when he said to his
family he was moving to New York to make
movies he said I might as well been
saying I'm going to Mars to colonize the
red planet you know I mean no that's
what other people do that a kid from
Georgia doesn't do that and and I just
try to convince people that that just
relax oh my god relax just write it
don't worry about it yeah some people
will hate it
some people will love it beetle - beetle
just got a lot of terrible reviews they
were wrong I I was told by one of the
most prominent executives in Hollywood I
was ruining my career he was wrong
people but what what so what if they're
right you'll write another one and and
and I and I love doing free writes I
love saying reveal a little something
about yourself this is a safe place and
it's amazing what comes out if people
give themselves permission to do that
but it's hardly a perfect process and
and so many people will be so afraid of
how they're going to be judged by their
words on a computer screen for God's
sakes it's a screenplay okay it's a f'n
screenplay get over it you know I mean
but they will be so afraid of how
they're going to be judged and how
they're going to be judged of failure
that they'll just quit and they'll
figure out something else to do so I try
I try and I try to just loosen people up
and say feel is feel free to fail I
started surfing again a couple years ago
after after 40 years of not doing it and
I was a really good surfer 40 years ago
and I started again I was terrible I
mean I did everything I thought I knew
you know I knew it in principle but I
had to learn again
and then all of a sudden I started
getting good again but it was after a
lot of falling off a surfboard and
embarrassing myself but but it's it's
it's that it's that same thing you fall
off you fall off you fall off and then
you don't and that's and writing is
you're going to write badly and write
badly and then you're going to write
good
you